le premier ministre en france le pouvoir
est une drôle de bête à deux têtes les
spécialistes de sciences politiques
disent dans leur langage savant que le
pouvoir exécutif est bicéphale
les deux têtes sont celles du président
et celle du premier ministre le
président élu par les français fixe les
grandes orientations du pays
il choisit son premier ministre qui doit
les mettre en oeuvre
autant dire que celui ci a le nez dans
le moteur de la machine france et les
mains dans le cambouis
s'il y a une crise grave catastrophe
naturelle ou aux accidents industriels
par exemple c'est toujours lui qu'on
réveille et qui doivent y trouver les
solutions
il n'a pas le droit de se tromper
d'ailleurs il peut être renvoyé à
n'importe quel moment par le président
ou mais ça n'est jamais arrivé par un
vol spécial de l'assemblée le premier
ministre et le chef de la majorité c'est
lui qui tentent de faire régner
l'harmonie dans le gouvernement
et ce n'est pas simple parce que parmi
les ministres il y en a beaucoup qui ne
sont pas d'accord entre eux ainsi
souvent le ministre du budget qui
s'occupe de l'état des finances de la
france
s'embrouille avec les autres ministres
la ministre de l'éducation veut
embaucher plein de profs acheter des
ordinateurs pour toutes les écoles bref
elle a besoin de beaucoup d'argent mais
le ministre de la défense aussi il en
veut beaucoup pour entretenir les sous
marins nucléaires et pour entraîner les
soldats qui ne doivent pas servir
simplement à défiler le 14 juillet du
coup c'est toujours pareil la ministre
de l'éducation et le ministre de la
défense mais aussi celui de l'intérieur
celui de la justice celui de la culture
et ainsi de suite passent leur temps à
téléphoner au premier ministre pour
défendre leur budget et le premier
ministre doit trancher
il ne tranche pas les ministres rassurez
vous ça c'était pendant la révolution
il tranche dans les dépenses et
naturellement il se fait plein d'ennemis
son boulot principal finalement c'est de
dire non par exemple non ce n'est pas
possible d'augmenter le salaire minimum
alors il devient vite impopulaire
il faut être résistant et courageux pour
être premier ministre
on dit qu'il est le fusible du président
il le protège en captant sur lui le
mécontentement qui du coup ne va pas sur
le président il suffit pour comprendre
l'enfer qu'il vit de regarder une photo
d'un premier ministre le jour de sa
nomination est une autre au moment de
son départ on dirait qu'il a pris 10 ans
ça fait que le monstre à deux têtes à
une drôle de touche
pourtant les hommes et les femmes
politiques rêvent tous d'être un jour
premier ministre parce que malgré tout
c'est vraiment là qu'ils tiennent les
manettes du pouvoir